in this video you're going to learn how
to write a sinusoidal equation given the
maximum and the minimum points and here
are some formulas that you might want to
write down and memorize we'll talk about
them as we go through the video so the
first thing we're given here is a Max of
pi over 6 comma 3 that's a high point on
the graph and a minimum of 2 pi over 3
comma 1 what I like to do just to
visualize is just to draw a rough sketch
so say for example if Pi / 6 uh comma 3
is right about here and let's say the
minimum here at 2 pi over 3 Let's just
say it's somewhere over
here uh and that's going to put us down
here at like negative one so I'll just
put it right right there so basically
our graph looks something like this and
then you can see what's interesting is
from the
maximum to the
minimum just like when you look at your
basic cosine graph see how the cosine
starts at the maximum and then it goes
down to the minimum that's only half of
one period or one cycle so you can see
that this graph actually would continue
on like that right to complete one full
period so that's interesting so let's
take a look at that piece for a minute
so if we take this distance which is 2
piun over 3 minus pi/ 6 that's half of
one period so if we were to double this
that's going to give us what our period
is
okay so let's go ahead and get a common
denominators I'm going to multiply the
top here by two and the Bottom by two so
that will give us 4 pi/ 6 uh minus 1 pi
over
6 which is 3 pi over
6 and 3 pi over 6 is the same as Pi /
2 and then time 2 is equal to Pi so now
we know what our period is is pi but the
reason we're finding the period is so
that we can solve for this B value this
coefficient here that comes to the left
or in front of the X and there's a
formula that you're going to want to use
the period is equal to 2 Pi / B so in
this case we know our period is pi
that's equal to 2 Pi / B you can cross
multiply and see that 2 pi * 1 is 2 pi
that's equal to Pi * B divide both sides
by
pi and you can see that b is coming out
to two so that's what this value is
right right here now we're going to show
you how to write the graph as both a s
graph and a cosine graph and there's
more than one answer for these problems
because it depends on what point you're
using as the starting point so for this
first uh one let's go ahead and focus on
the cosine graph and cosine see when
you're at x equals z see how cosine
starts at the maximum and it kind of
goes down from there so let's pretend
like this is a cosine graph starting
here okay so that means it's been
shifted from the origin right Pi / 6
okay and we're going to talk about that
so let's go ahead and uh put our B value
in which is two now let's talk about the
amplitude the amplitude is like how high
the waves are but when you measure that
amplitude you're really measuring it
from the the midline okay so like when
you look at cosine here you say well hm
you can see it has an amplitude of one
it's like you're standing on the beach
and you're basically saying okay how
high are the waves well you're not
measuring from down here you're
measuring from this
middle level okay which is the x-axis so
you could measure here this is one or
from the midline to the minimum that's
one when you think about the amplitude
it's like a the absolute value it's just
distance which is positive which is one
now if it's reflected we could make it a
negative at that point but the actual
amplitude itself is a is a positive
number so what I like to do sometimes is
I like to try to sketch in like a
midline and I can see that this is the
midline right here I can see from here
to the minimum is two from here to the
maximum is two so I can see that that
amplitude is two now some students may
have a little challenge doing that
depending on the numbers that they give
you so you might want to use this
formula right here the max minus the Min
/ two so let's go ahead and do that so
we have the max which is three minus the
Min which is -1 / two When You Subtract
it's like adding the opposite that's 4
over 2 which is equal to two so that's
going to be our our a value our
amplitude our vertical stretch we've got
our B value which is
two now let's look at the K value now
the K value you can see here that's
basically how far the graph is shifted
up or down and that midline is normally
right here at the x axis right you can
see that's been shifted up one again
depending on the numbers that you're
given it might be a little bit difficult
to find this so what you can use is this
formula here you can say it's the
average of the Max and the Min so it
means you add the Max and the Min and
you divide by two so let's go ahead and
do that so the max we said was three
plus the minimum which we said was -1 /
two so that comes out to 2 / 2 which is
equal to one so we can see this is
shifted up one unit Okay so we've got
our a our B and our K how do we find our
H value remember the H is the horizontal
shift it's our phase shift and again we
said that cosine we're going to work
with that one first cosine starts right
here at the maximum when is zero it's at
that high point so how do we get from uh
where this graph would normally start
which would be right here okay it's been
shifted right pi over 6 so let's go
ahead and put everything uh together
now and what do we have we have y equals
our amplitude which is
two cosine our B value which is
2 x - < / 6 now remember whatever's
group of the X has the opposite effect
so minus pi/ 6 is actually shifting at
right pi/ 6 if this was plus pi over 6
it' be shifting at left pi over six and
then our K value we said it was shifting
up one so this is our sinusoidal
equation given the Max and the Min now
you might say well Mario what happens if
I want to write this as a s graph and
not a cosine graph okay now remember
sign looks like this okay if it hasn't
been stretched or shifted it starts here
at the midline at the origin it goes up
to the maximum back to the midline down
to the minimum back to the midline right
so that's your basic sign graph now if
we look at this graph here see this
point right here where it crosses the
midline this is like a
quarter of a period like 1/4 of the
period we said from the max to the Min
that was half the period right so what's
this distance here well we said that uh
that came out to Pi / 2 so half of
that's going to be be Pi 4 so if I was
to go another Pi 4 here to the left
right see if I was to kind of graph this
what's pi 6 minus pi over 4 let's figure
out what that is we got to get common
denominator so multiply top and bottom
by two top and bottom by three so we
have 2 piun over
12 minus 3 pi over 12 is equal
to1 pi over 12 that means that when I
graph this it's going to be something
like this okay right here this point is
pi over 12 and you're right at that
midline okay now we're starting to see
okay this looks a little bit more like a
sign graph from here to here right again
s and cosine are basically the same
graph it's just like this s shaped wave
this sinusoidal wave it's just a matter
of you know where's your starting point
where's you know where's the initial
point if it's uh starts at the max we
think about a cosine if it starts at the
midline we tend to think of the sign
graph so let's look at this as a sign
graph now now what's interesting is the
amplitude the height of the waves is
going to be the same whether it's a sign
or cosine it's just the same graph right
so that means this is going to be a is 2
same as this one
s the period is going to be the same
okay that's how long it takes to to
complete one cycle or repeat now you
might be saying Mario this two what's
going on with this two Well normally the
period is 2 pi for s or cosine but when
it's group with the X like this it has
the opposite effect you're actually
dividing the X values by two which is
going to make the period just one Pi if
this was 1/2 it would actually be
multiplying the uh X values by the
reciprocal two so this has like the
opposite effect and then with our s
graph we said normally the sign graph
would start you know right here at the
at the um midline here right at the U
when X is zero it start right at this
point here so you can see this graph is
shifting actually left pi over 12 and up
one right so to shift to the left this
is actually going to be plus pi/2
remember again whatever is group with
the X has the opposite effect that plus
pi over 12 shifts left pi over 12 and
then the K value was the same for the
cosine it just shifted the graph up one
so what's nice about you know you can
start with either s or cosine the a the
B the K are exactly the same it's just a
matter of the phase shift the left and
right um shift now you might be saying
Mario aren't there other answers and
there are like you could say well maybe
I want to start my S graph right here
and I'm going to go like that and make
this the beginning point and that's fine
the only thing that will change though
is this phase shift this H value here
okay and uh same thing with cosine you
could say well maybe I want the cosine
graph to start right here and go like
that and just say that I shifted it
right so much and up so much so a lot of
correct answers I tend to pick the ones
that are where it's not shifted too far
from the origin and um you got it now if
you want to see another example maybe
you want to test yourself uh go ahead
and follow me over to that video that I
did right there we'll get some more
practice maybe you can pause a video and
try one on your own I'll see you in that
video